donc le parc s'appelle goma six parcs et
il est situé entre la 20e et 21e rue
entre park avenue et la troisième et
c'est uniquement les gens qui ont la
drees sur le parc qui a le droit
d'acheter la clé donc tous les ans on
achète la clé et on a toute une équipe
de jardiniers qui toutes les saisons on
a des fleurs différentes et on organise
des événements alors il ya le moment de
pâques halloween et noël alors c'est un
parc privé c'est comme ça qu'on peut oui
c'est le parc privé de new york
c'est le seul qui me lie à une clé c'est
une seule où il y a trois pages de
règlement on n'a pas le droit d'inviter
pas le droit de se marier dans le par
paroisse de chiens elle est d'ailleurs
si vous voyez le parc dans certains
films parce qu'il ya eu des films qui se
sont tournés les chiens étaient toujours
portés par les acteurs et je trouve ça
toujours très drôle